Italian officials now say at least 39
people died in the collapse of a giant
highway bridge a rescue effort continued
around the clock with searchers looking
for more survivors Charlie d'Agata is at
the scene in Genoa Italy where the
Morandi bridge fell leaving a massive
gap in that highway charlie good morning
good morning well those rescue efforts
are continuing beneath the bridge even
if the hope of finding survivors is
dimming government officials have
arrived here this morning they're facing
growing demands to explain exactly how
something like this could have happened
residents awoke to a new skyline and a
new reality the bridge that suddenly
ceased to exist taking so many lives
with it rescuers with sniffer dogs
searched through the night in a
desperate hope that somewhere buried
beneath the huge slabs of concrete
someone had managed to survive during a
heavy rainstorm the bridge suddenly
plunged a hundred fifty feet down into a
riverbed buildings and city streets
taking dozens of vehicles and those
inside with it
Diaby DiGiorgio shot that cellphone
footage they captured the moment I this
morning you wake up it's a dream call a
bad dream but it's not a very
the collapse of what has now been called
the bridge of death left a gaping hole
in the heart of this city and unanswered
questions about whether this structure
that local residents say was under a
constant state of repair was still fit
to do the job a half-century after it
was built
60,000 vehicles crossed the Morandi
bridge every day families on summer
vacations employees on their commute
truckers ferrying goods from one side of
the city to the other victims who but
for a few seconds on that bridge either
way would be alive today the public
prosecutor has already announced that a
criminal investigation will be underway
to determine whether negligence was
involved but locals here have been
expressing fears for years that that
bridge would never survive an earthquake
gaol and then seconds met the difference
between life and death thank you Charlie
d'Agata reporting from Genoa Italy today